you guys rest yourselves thank you so
much it is really great to be here today
with all of you we have with us today
college and universities presidents we
have experts and advocates and civic and
business leaders and I want to thank all
of you for taking the time to be here
today and for working every day to help
young people pursue their education and
build brighter futures for themselves
and for our country and I'd also like us
to give a really big hand to Troy
that's pretty powerful stuff and present
it so eloquently I know yesterday I met
Roy he was nervous I don't really know
why you were nervous you're pretty
awesome thank you so Joyce story reminds
us all of the limitless capacity that
lies within all of our young people no
matter where they come from or how much
money they have Troy is an example of
why we all should care deeply about this
issue and Troy and millions of others
like him or why I care so much about
this issue and why in the coming years
I'm going to be spending more and more
my time focusing on education because as
everyone here knows education is the key
to success for so many kids and my goal
specifically is to reach out directly to
young people and encourage them to take
charge of their futures and complete an
education beyond high school and I'm
doing this because so often when we talk
about education we talk about our young
people and what we need to do for them
we talk about the programs we need to
create for them about the resources we
need to devote to them but we must
remember that education is a two-way
bargain and while there is so much more
we must do for our kids at the end of
the day as Troy described the person who
has the most say over whether or not a
student succeeds is the student him or
herself ultimately they are the ones
sitting in that classroom they're the
ones who have to set goals for
themselves and work hard to achieve
those goals every single day so my hope
is that with this new effort that
instead of talking about our kids we
talk with our kids I want to hear what's
going on in their lives I want to
inspire them to step up and commit to
their education so they can have
opportunities they never even dreamed of
I'm doing this because that story
opportunity through education is the
story of my life and I want them to know
that it can be their story too but only
only if they devote themselves to
continuing their education past high
school and for many students that might
mean attending a college or university
like the ones many of you represent for
others it might mean choosing a
community college it might mean pursuing
short-term professional training but no
matter what they do I want to make sure
that students believe that they have
what it takes to succeed beyond high
school that's going to be my message to
young people but here's the thing I know
that that message alone isn't enough
like I said this is a two-way street and
that means we all have to step up
because make no mistake about it these
kids are smart they will notice if we're
not holding up our end of the bargain
they will notice if we tell them about
applying for college or financial aid
but then no one's there to help them
choose the right school or fill out the
right forms they will notice if we tell
them that they're good enough to
graduate from college but then no
college ask them to apply no college
invites them to visit their campus and
so we've got to recommit ourselves to
helping these kids pursue their
education and as you discussed in your
first panel today one of the first steps
is getting more underserved young people
on to college campuses the fact is that
right now we are missing out on so much
potential because so many promising
young people young people like Troy who
have the talent it takes to succeed
simply don't believe that College can be
a reality for them too many of them are
falling through the cracks and all of
you know that all too well and that's
why so many of you already finding new
ways to reach out to the underserved
students in your communities you're
helping them navigate the financial
and college admissions process and
you're helping them find schools that
match their abilities and interests and
I know from my own experience just how
important all of that work is that
you're doing see the truth is that if
Princeton hadn't found my brother as a
basketball recruit and if I hadn't seen
that he could succeed on a campus like
that never would have occurred to me to
apply to that school never and I know
that there are so many kids out there
just like me kids who have a world of
potential but maybe their parents never
went to college or maybe they've never
been encouraged to believe they could
succeed there and so that means it's our
job to find those kids it's our job to
help them understand their potential and
then get them enrolled in a college that
can help them meet their needs but then
we all know that just getting into
school is only half the story because
once students are there they have got to
graduate and that's not always easily
easy especially given what many of these
kids are dealing with when they get to
campus hi just just think about it you
just heard us snip it from joy just just
to make it to college these kids have
already overcome so much neighborhoods
riddled with crime and drugs moms and
dads who weren't around too many nights
when they had to go to bed hungry but as
I tell these kids when I talk to them we
can't think about those experiences that
they've had his weaknesses just the
opposite they're actually strengths in
facing and overcoming these challenges
these kids have developed skills like
grit and resilience that many of their
peers will never be able to compete with
never and when they get out in the world
those are the exact skills they will
need to succeed and they will succeed
but imagine how hard it is to realize
that when you first get to college
you're in a whole new
world you might have trouble making
friends because you don't see any peers
who come from a background like yours
you might be worried about paying for
classes and food and room and board
because you have never had to set your
own budget before you might be feeling
guilty when you call home because mom
and dad are wondering why you didn't get
a job so you could help support their
family those are the kinds of obstacles
these kids are facing right from day one
but let's be clear all of that isn't
just a challenge for them is a challenge
for folks like us who are committed to
helping them succeed and make no mistake
about it that is our mission not simply
giving speeches or raising money or
hosting conferences but to take real
meaningful action that will help our
young people get into college and more
importantly actually get their degree
and here's the good news time and again
you all have shown that you have the
experience the passion and the resources
to help these young people thrive for
example in recent decades you've
realized that students from across the
socio-economic spectrum have been coming
to campus with more and more issues like
eating disorders and learning
disabilities emotional challenges like
depression and anxiety and so much more
and luckily you all have not shied away
from these issues I've seen it I worked
at a university and you haven't said
these are our problems we're University
not a hospital or Counseling Center know
you've stepped up and while there's
still work left to do on these issues
were you working every day to support
these kids through treatment programs
and outreach initiatives and and support
groups because you know that these
issues have a huge impact on whether
students can learn and succeed at your
school so now as you begin to see more
and more underserved students on your
campuses we need you to direct that same
energy and determination toward helping
these kids face their unique challenges
now fortunately you've already got the
expertise you
need to address these these issues and
simply by building on what you're
already doing best you can make real
differences for these kids and that's
what so many of you are doing with
commitments you made here at the summit
for example every school offers
financial aid services but listen to
what the University of Minnesota is
doing they're committing to expand those
services to include financial literacy
programs to help students and their
families manage the cost of college and
every school has advisors who
desperately want their students to
succeed Oregon Tech is committing to set
up a text message program so that these
advisors can connect more easily with
students who need some extra
encouragement or academic support and
every college has orientation programs
or learning communities to help students
transition to college and many of the
schools here today are supplementing
those programs by partnering with
organizations like the posse foundation
so that underserved students can connect
and build a social network before they
even step foot on campus and those were
the types of resources that help the kid
like me not just survive but thrive at a
school like Princeton when I first
arrived at school as a first generation
college student I didn't know anyone on
campus except my brother I didn't know
how to pick the right classes or find
the right buildings I didn't even bring
the right size sheets for my dorm room
bed I realized those bids were so long
so I was a little overwhelmed and a
little isolated but then I had an
opportunity to participate in a
three-week on-campus orientation program
that helped me get a feel for the rhythm
of college life and once school started
I discovered the campus cultural center
the third world center where I found
students and staff who came from
families and communities that were
similar to my own and they understood
what I was going through they were there
to listen when I was feeling frustrated
they were there to answer the questions
I was too embarrassed to ask anyone else
and if it weren't for those resources
and the friends and the mentors I
honestly don't know how I would have
made it through college but instead I
graduated at the top of my class I went
to law school and you know the rest so
whether it's aligning with an
organization like posse or offering a
new advising or mentoring program or
creating a central space where students
can connect with one another you all can
take simple steps that can determine
whether these kids give up and drop out
or step up and thrive and that's not
just good for these young people it's
good for your schools because if you
embrace and empower these students and
if you make sure they have good campus
experiences then they're going to stay
engaged with your school for decades
after they graduate they will be dressed
up in school colors at homecoming games
they'll be asking to serve on your
committees and advisory boards and
they'll be doing their part when
fundraising season rolls around so
believe me these will be some of the
best alumni you could possibly ask for
because after everything these kids will
have overcome to get into college and
get through college believe me they will
have all the skills they need to run our
businesses and our labs and to teach in
our classrooms and to lead our
communities just look at me look at Troy
and the countless success stories from
the organizations and schools
represented here in this room that's how
we will win this country we will win by
tapping the full potential of all of our
young people so that we can grow our
economy and move this country forward
let me tell you that is something that
my husband understands deeply because
his life story just like mine is rooted
in education as well and as president
that is what drives him every single day
his goal of expanding opportunity to
millions of Americans who are strike
to build better futures for themselves
for their families and for our country
as well so now it is my pleasure to
introduce my husband the President of
the United States Barack Obama